(rumbling)
(eerie music)
(soft music)
(static)
(piano music)
(soft relaxing music)
(soft rock music)
(perplexed music)
(chiming music)
(soft relaxing music)
("Wait" )
♫ As long as we're together
♫ This moment last forever
♫ And what will she say
♫ Will my heart be torn
♫ Maybe there's some else to keep her warm
♫ Maybe she's too shy to comment
♫ 21, and too hard to call it
♫ Let's make it last forever
♫ 'Cause the night's still young
♫ It's true, I feel the pressure
♫ Every time you're gone
♫ As long as we're together
♫ This moment last forever
♫ Let's make this last forever
♫ 'Cause the night's still young
♫ It's true, I feel the pressure
♫ Every time you're gone
♫ As long as we're together
♫ This moment last forever
♫ Let's make it last forever
♫ 'Cause the night's still young
♫ It's true, I feel the pressure
♫ Every time you're gone
♫ As long as we're together
♫ This moment last forever
(soft music)